on
[Musique]
va parler entrepreneuriat aujourd'hui
comme l'introduction était très bien
fait je m'occupe du média j'ai un pote
dans la com qui aujourd'hui compte une
petite dizaine de personnes qui fait à
peu près entre 35 et 36 millions
d'impressions chaque mois sur tous nos
contenus on va se parler surtout de
l'aspect entrepreneuriat un peu moins
business mais plutôt comment on se lance
pourquoi on se lance et qu'est ce qu'il
ya derrière cette aventure elle est
belle de l'extérieur mais à l'intérieur
laurent dont l'associé avec moi c'est
que sa demande certains sacrifices
on va passer du coup la première slide
je vais faire comme ça je suis désolé ça
sera pas un talk sur comment je sauve le
monde ou comment j'ai fait 10 millions
de chiffre d'affaires en deux mois ça va
juste être un petit peu plus simple ça
va être ma vie et mon expérience
entrepreneuriale j'espère qu'on va quand
même vous intéresser
notre première question ensemble
aujourd'hui j'ai quinze minutes tu
essaies de faire simple efficace complet
et de vous donner envie aussi de vous
lancer après ça pourquoi se lancer
comment
comprendre que c'est le moment de se
lancer
grosse question pour en parler pendant
dix ans pourquoi silence et déjà je vais
prendre mon cas perso il n'y a pas eu un
jour où je me suis réveillé que je me
suis dit tiens je vais lancer ça je vais
faire ce business je vais être
indépendant donc j'avais pas le pourquoi
j'avais encore moins le comment
pourquoi me lancer en fait c'était
plutôt une somme de choses
d'expériences de rencontres de stage qui
parfois ont été très bons mais parfois
un peu moins et
pourquoi se lancer je me suis posé des
questions sur qui est ce que j'étais les
gens que je côtoyais ce que j'avais
envie de leur ressembler les rencontres
en stage qu'elle était bonne pas
forcément donc c'était pas une volonté
de monter quelque chose c'est surtout
nouveau lui non volonté d'être comme les
gens que je rencontrais parce que ça
m'allait pas la manière de bosser
m'allait pas les échanges avec les gens
m'avaient pas c'était pas du tout ce à
quoi je m'attendais en master 2 à faire
ça et sur comment est ce qu'on sait que
c'est le moment alors j'ai pas de
solution miracle on sait pas en fait on
sait pas la seule chose que je peux vous
dire c'est quand ça commence à trotter
un peu dans votre tête et vous commencez
à vous demander tiens qu'est-ce que je
qu'est ce que je pourrais faire si
j'étais pas là qu'est ce que j'aurais
fait si j'étais ailleurs
c'est à partir du moment où vous posez
plus de questions sur ce qui se serait
passé si vous n'étiez pas dans ce stage
là dans cette boîte là que vous
commencez à vraiment vous dire tiens
c'est un truc qui cloche est ce qu'il
n'ya pas un peu plus sympa à faire
ailleurs donc ya pas de moments clés n'y
a pas un jour on se réveille tiens je
vais monter ma boîte je sais ce que je
vais faire non on apprend à se connaître
donc moi le le média était monté avec
laurent quand j'étais étudiant donc
c'est avoir une période de la vie où on
se cherche on veut être quelqu'un de
bien ok ça veut dire quoi quelqu'un de
bien ça va être notre deuxième slight ça
va être faire des choix et les assumer
ça va être hyper intéressant de se
projeter là dessus savoir faire des
choix une nécessité
toute ma vie se résume à travers le
choix
le choix de de partir à paris faire ses
études le choix de bosser sur tel sujet
le soit le choix de deux de se lancer ou
pas
toute la vie c'est une question de choix
en fait ça paraît très bête mais c'est
ça au fond du compte c'est monté sa
boîte c'est cool mais des choses cool
des choses un peu moins cool mais c'est
que des choix
et la question c'est pas tant qu est ce
que je choisis parce que quand on
choisit on renonce connaît tous cette
phrase évidemment qu'est ce qu'elle dit
derrière elle dit qu'
il faut avoir un côté où on assume
derrière je fais pas de sport pas de
souci par contre si j'ai mal au dos à 30
ans j'assume je monte ma boîte je vois
pas souvent ma copine j'assume c'est des
choix et c'est pas que du positif c'est
pas que d'une élection que du négatif
pardon c'est une somme de choix j'ai une
anecdote à vous livrer sur ce jugement
ce sujet du choix qui a été
symptomatique de ma vie en fin de match
je ne vis que j'ai que 27 ans et de ce
qu'est ce qui s'est passé après j'étais
étudiant en dut publicité à nancy et
j'avais été pris en troisième année dans
une super école que je voulais trop
faire dans un master dans une licence
iii que je voulais trop faire qui était
hyper intéressante donc j'ai fait le
choix passer les concours du coup j'ai
fait le choix de beauce et donc les
autres sortes et ce qui est à la fac et
j'ai été acceptée alors là mes parents
étaient très contents petite parenthèse
avant j'ai juste fait le choix d'aller
en dut et pas en prépa donc là les
parents n'étaient pas ultra content non
plus quand j'étais pris en préparer mer
la féverole là il y en a qui s'en sort
donc j'ai fait le choix d'aller en dut
ensuite j'ai fait le choix d'aller à
lille ma mère était pas forcément ravi
parce que le petit s'en aller mais
j'étais content j'ai déménagé j'ai pris
toutes mes affaires je suis allé à lille
trop bien première semaine j'étais censé
être en marketing premières semaines
j'avais des cours de fiscalité
deuxième jour match financière
troisième jour analyse statistique
j'ai fait un dut publicité donc je me
suis dit alors en fait il se passe
quelque chose qui va pas du tout
on n'est pas clair là on n'est pas du
tout et du coup je me suis dit ma mère
qui m'écrivait a du coup la première
semaine ça va ouais ça va c'est pas du
tout ce que j'ai envie de faire mais ça
va parce qu'on a déménagé il ya pas de
soucis on a payé ton appart que le deal
avec les parents il est très clair c'est
qu'on n'est pas millionnaire on te paye
ton appart par contre ton master ta
licence c'est pas 10 11 12 sur 20 si tu
les clac à 15 donc là c'était moyen bien
partie pour ça avec des matchs
financière donc j'ai pris ça a été le
premier choix vraiment que je trouve
symptomatique de ce qui se passe dans ma
vie aujourd'hui c'est de dire ok ça va
pas le faire j'aurais peut-être pas mon
année je l'aurais soit en redoublant
soit qu'une pauvre moyenne du coup mon
master il sera pas celui que je veux et
encore moins le master 2 donc j'ai dit à
mes parents j'ai dit ok écouter vider la
chambre parce que je reviens
il était du genre y reviennent bien donc
et j'aurai retrouvé un du coup j'ai
contacté un professeur dans une école de
cinéma à nancy j'ai dit écoute et voilà
j'ai pris dans l école ça me plaît pas
c'est parce que je suis au fond de moi
je suis j'ose espérer que quelqu'un de
créatif j'espère sais pas ce que je vais
faire les mannes financières ou que j'ai
enlevé un mail il m'a répondu une
semaine après j'étais pris dans la
licence iii du visuel
à partir de là ça a roulé j'ai aimé ce
que je faisais master 1 celui que je
voulais je les ai eus et master 2 j'ai
terminé à deux films c'est ce que je
voulais depuis le post bac donc faire
des choix c'est extrêmement important
dans la mesure où il faut les assumer
parce que j'aurais pu dire ben je reste
à lille je fais le choix de rester à
lille mais derrière qu'est ce qui se
serait passé ce que j'aurais été heureux
de d'arriver avec une pauvre licence
avec une pauvre moyenne mes parents qui
m'ont dit mais en fait tu as fait ton
école qu est-ce qui va pas donc la
notion du choix elle est importante et
cette anecdote elle illustre un peu ce
qu'on fait aujourd'hui sur le site les
choix des gens à qui on travaille le
choix de bosser par le soir
le choix de voir un peu moins ses
collègues ou ses amis et en même temps
c'est ultra positif parce qu'on serait
avec un vrai but et on se réveille avec
une volonté de faire quelque chose ça va
être ma slide après
voilà comment l'entreprise le programme
change ma vie au quotidien
il ya plusieurs il ya plusieurs choses
et pour faire suite à ce que je vous dis
sur le choix ça change ma vie dans la
mesure où j'ai un but en fait on passe
tellement de temps au boulot que nous on
a la chance d'avoir créé notre propre
job ça c'est magnifique et on se
réveille avec un but et c'est ça qui
change ma vie en fait c'est à dire que
matin je me lève je sais où je vais en
tout cas jusqu'à midi après je vais voir
parce qu'entre là c'est un peu ça aussi
ça rythme mais journée ça me donne un
but et en fait on est tellement
confronté à un travail aujourd'hui le
travail avec
majuscule que l'on peut pas faire un
boulot qui qu'on aime pas donc on a la
chance c'est un luxe on le sait très
bien et je remercie tous les gens qui
nous suivent et qui font vivre le média
mais on sait très bien que c'est un luxe
donc il faut pas il faut pas passer à
côté de ça et un temps faut se donner
donc commença à rythme ma vie bah ça lui
donne du sens tout simplement en fait ça
donne du sens parce que
je sais où je veux aller je suis
confronté à des problématiques bah ouais
c'est des choix ouais je vois moins des
gens même temps je fais le choix de de
faire d'autres choses et encore une fois
il faut les assumer après donc je fais
une petite anecdote sur le le sujet du
bac en philosophie j'ai fait un bac
littéraire en philo et encore une fois
c'était symptomatique de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui j'avais eu comme
problématique au bac le travail rend-il
libre
alors
gt gt pas à mon aise pour répondre et
lorsque j'avais passé bosser sujet
et j'en suis pas trop mal sorti parce
que j'ai eu un 16 et en fait ça je me
suis projeté sur wayne le travail rend
libre en fait ouais parce que c'est à
travers le travail qu'on se réalise en
tant qu homme avec un grand a jetés à
travers le travail qu' on redonne du
sens à sa vie et qu'on se réveille le
matin ça peut paraître des gros des
grosses phrases des grands mots mais
pour moi pour mon expérience perso c'est
ce qui me rêve tous les matins c'est
pourquoi je me lève la relation avec les
gens avec les clients j'ai commencé très
tôt j'étais étudiant en deuxième année
quand on a lancé la boîte
parlez à des clients quant à 22 balles
et c'est pas simple donc ça te donne un
but ça te
change ta vie en fait ça tu te tue à un
rôle et tu te sens important et surtout
tu te donne du sens et le matin c'est
hyper important dans la mesure où à côté
toi ya des gens qui bossent avec toi et
ça c'est le plus important j'ai revenir
juste dessus juste après c'est comment
on partage sa passion comment on amène
les gens avec nous ce que nous on se
fait une un job sur mesure comme je
disais c'est cool n'a dû aller couler
c'est du taf très bien mais on se fait
un peu notre vie sur mesure les gens qui
bossent avec nous c'est pas leur projet
donc il faut réussir à les accompagner
faut le réussir les mettre dedans moi me
lever tôt et bosser tard avec laurent ce
n'est pas un souci c'est notre boîte par
contre comment on transmet ce message là
comment les gens qu'on rencontre
nos partenaires les gens à qui on bosse
comme on leur transmet ça ça va être mon
quatrième point
yes comment faire pour partager son état
d'esprit ben là c'est très simple en
fait vous êtes le meilleur ambassadeur
de votre projet de clash parlera sans
doute à des étudiants à des actifs à des
seniors je ne sais pas vraiment qui
composent ce public mais comprenez
peut-être une chose si je peux essayer
donner un conseil de manière très très
humble comme une fois j'ai que 27 ans
la transmission de la passion c'est
hyper important parce qu'on est les
meilleurs ambassadeurs de ce en quoi on
croit si on se réveille et qu'on
n'arrive pas à transmettre notre projet
personne va y croire à notre place en
fait si votre idée votre concept vous
n'avez pas le pitch et vous n'avez pas à
le mettre du sens à personne va dire à
trop bien j'y crois à fond si même toi
même tu y crois pas en fait ça peut
paraître très bête encore une fois mais
vous êtes les porte-étendards de vos
projets de vos passions de vos sujets
donc transmettez ça et ça passe par les
rencontres donc les semis de graines ça
fait sens de sans parler aujourd'hui
c'est les rencontres c'est comment on
arrive à échanger avec des gens
transmettre quelque chose et se dire
cette personne à être une bonne personne
et ça revient sur ce que je vous disais
juste avant sur les choix
je pense que personne se lève et se
niche une mauvaise personne d'accord
mais cela personne qui se dit mais c'est
ce que je me dis je pense que je suis
une bonne personne mais c'est pas
suffisant
il faut que je le fasse dans les faits
faut que j'assume d'avoir fait le choix
de dire officiellement je suis une bonne
personne donc je suis agréable je donne
des conseils j'écoute je vois des gens
sans que ce soit intéressé je prends des
risques géant prend pour les autres pour
des amis que je considère donc ya aussi
cette volonté de transmettre d'avoir une
sorte d'aura autour de soi et vous savez
très bien je vais pas parler de
philosophie ou de chakra mais quand on
renvoie des choses positives la ville
est assez bien fait parce qu'en vrai il
se passe des belles choses et quand on
est dans le noir avec laurent des fois
ya des semaines où c'est très très dur
et qu'on se remet un peu la tête à
l'endroit quand je dis ok ça va le faire
mais pas dans le rouge on se remet sur
le sujet on retransmet c'est exactement
cette question on retransmet à l'équipe
qui on bosse
une motivation pareil pour nos clients
pareil pour nos partenaires ils sentent
que il se passe quelque chose de positif
donc cette transmission là elle passe
aussi par la rencontre donc je trouvais
ça assez intéressant de faire le lien
avec ce ce thème global c'est pourquoi
on est réuni aujourd'hui pour ce telex
et mon cinquième point
c'est le sans doute le plus important
qui va résumer tout ce que je viens de
vous dire sans être trop boring et sans
non plus donner trop de leçons le but
n'est pas d'être d'être incisif sur les
conseils simplement de ces de partager
j'ai pas dogmatique simplement voilà
notre vision voilà ce qu'on essaie de
faire
prenez votre vie en main ça paraît très
simple
j'ai eu beaucoup de chance effectivement
mes parents m'ont toujours fait mon
appart quand j'ai fait mes études à
paris ou à lille bonjour je vous
rappelle le deal qui est d'avoir une
bonne moyenne sinon je repartais vite
mais on a eu de la chance par ailleurs
on a su provoquer la chance sur d'autres
sujets on a su
faire des choix qui ont été les bons
parfois les mauvais mais comme je dis il
faut les assumer et du cou prenez votre
vie en main c'est décider de qui vous
avez envie d'être ou est ce que vous
voulez allez et comment vous le faites
si j'avais pas fait ce choix là de me
barrer de mon master de ma licence 3 je
serais peut-être pas là si j'avais fait
le choix d'aller en prépa j'aurais eu
peut-être un pauvre dix ans de moyenne
si au lycée j'avais fait le choix de
moins bavarde est en cours j'aurais
peut-être été pris en sport étude au
rugby tout cas pas été le cas ça que
j'ai bavardé
donc voilà c'est qu'une question de
choix et de prendre un petit peu de dire
quand est ce que je prends ma vie en
main sans se prendre pour des cadors ou
des seniors juste de se dire voilà
maintenant c'est moi qui décide je
décide que ce sujet là je vais le bon
c'est pour mon mari mon partiel j'ai
c'est que tel qui peu logique clients
c'est que je veux travailler donc il
faut que je connaisse le marché là il
faut que je bosse et surtout
je termine là dessus pour les votes ni
reprenez votre vie en main c'est aussi
rencontrer des personnes définies c'est
un peu ce que vous avez envie de faire
de voir et qui vous aviez envie de
rencontrer
et dans le cadre de ce thé dicks let's
meet again je terminerai là dessus les
premières rencontres sont hyper
importante et par l'occe allemand s'est
pas forcément les meilleures elles sont
souvent synonymes de retenue on n'est
pas hyper à l'aise on se livre pas on
n'est pas la même personne que on
pourrait avec nos amis lors d'une
deuxième entrevue donc la deuxième je te
la trouve toujours plus sincères plus
authentique donc on s'est vu une fois ce
soir très bien parfait moi je serais
heureux de vous revoir une deuxième fois
pour qu'elles sont encore plus
authentique et plus sincère donc l'ex
mitoyenne
[Musique]